The answer is our initial constraint would touch this guy over here.
The one to second motion touches these things over here.
The second to third, these guys, and then the landmark observation over here
puts something between x0 and the landmark
that sits here, here, here, here again, and here.
This observation over here puts something between x2 and the landmark--
these guys over here and the guys over here.
That means we have only the following places that are still 0.
This means there is no direct constraint between x2 and x0.
That is, there is no direct motion information between these guys,
and there is no direct constraint between x1 and L, which is this guy is missing over here.